Alright, so how are we going to figure this out?
>> By you letting them figure it out while I figure it out.
>> [LAUGH]
I think you should figure this out.
>> Okay let's figure it out.
>> It might not be obvious just looking at it blankly so why don't
we just throw in some values here. So, for example we can do this.
>> Mm-hm
>> Which is, it gets filled in
in both places. So the probability that thunder
is true given that lightning is false and storm is true, what is that number?
>> Well,
so we just have to find the place in our
little eight-row table where lightning is false and storm is true.
>> Lightning is false and storm is true, uh-huh.
>> Which is there.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And the probability that thunder is true is 0.04 divided by
0.4. Oh cause we're asking about thunder right. Was what's the probability that
thunder is true given that the other two things lightning is false and
storm is true so that's going to be divided by the point 4.
That's the setting that we're in.
>> Right and Point 04 divided by point 4 is point 1
>> Right so maybe we'll get lucky and it will work out the same
with the other one. So where do we have to look for that one?
>> Well now we have to look in the
row where lightning has false and storm is false.
>> Okay. Down here.
>> And look at the case where thunder is true,
and that's .03. .03 divided by .3 which is also .1.
>> Woo hoo! So that works as an answer. It turns out that, in fact,
no matter what you type into these two boxes, it
does, in fact, work. And what does that tell us?
>> Well, it tells us that it doesn't
matter what the value of storm is. We can
figure out the value of thunder by only looking
at the value of lightening. So, that is to
say, that the probability of thunder given lightning
and storm is equal to the probability of thunder
given lightening or that we have conditionally independent variables.
Yes, that's right. Storm is conditionally independent of thunder,
given lightning.
>> Right. So, the probability of thunder giving
li-, given lightning and storm, is equal to
the probability of thunder, given lightning. That means
that thunder and storm are conditionally independent, given lightning.
>> Or thunders conditionally independent of storm, given lightning.
>> Sure.
>> Very good. Alright. So now what we're going to
do next is say, Okay well given that we
have this nice property. And yeah, I, I worked
a little bit to make sure that the numbers,
worked out. It doesn't always happen this way,
but here we had some nice conditional independence and
what, we're going to do next is look
at a nice representation of that, kind of information.